[Music]
according to aesthetic evolution animals
are agents in their own evolution that
is it through their choices they end up
shaping their own species one of the
implications of this idea is a new
perspective on what happens when mate
choice is infringed or violated by
sexual violence or by coercion in in
animal species one prominent example of
this from our own research is on duck
sex Ducks are unusual among birds in
having both a typical mate choice
situation where male and females pair up
on the basis of display and preferences
and simultaneously other individuals
that force copulations on on female
ducks as they approach reproduction so
what that means is that as the eggs are
being laid females have to defend
themselves from forced copulations by
males now force copulation is the word
that biologists use now but for over a
century
biologists used the word rape in biology
now that was abandoned back in the 1970s
in response to the feminist movement and
Suzanne Brown Miller and her work
against our will proposing and
articulating a specifically social
context for rape in humans this led to
the creation of a euphemism forced
copulation in biology
unfortunately articulating sexual
violence in the animal world with these
euphemistic terms has led to scientists
losing track of the fact that forced
copulation is against the will of the
Ducks and by taking the aesthetic
perspective and trying to understand
what it is that individual females in
this case Ducks want we have arrived at
a new perspective on what it means when
they
get what they want right so in some ways
using socially sensitive euphemisms has
led to a imprecision or fuzziness in in
the science in the case of duck sex what
we find is that males can force
themselves on females because they're
among the few birds that still have a
penis and what we find in ducks is the
as a result of a female resistance and
male sexual violence we find a
co-evolutionary arms race between male
capacity to force and female resistance
in this case it takes place in the form
of a genital arms race the male's
evolved more elaborate and more
laterally armed penises and the females
evolved convoluted vaginal morphologies
that exclude the penis during force
copulation so the among the many weird
things that abduct penises is that
they're counterclockwise coiled well the
female vagina in ducks that have high
rates of resistance actually coils in
the opposite direction so they have
literally evolved an eighty screw device
in their vaginal tract that that
obstructs the intromission
of the penis during forced copulation
what that means is that the what that
Tea Party Senate candidate Todd akin
from Missouri said about women have a
way of shutting that whole thing down in
reference to rape is actually true of
ducks but in a way that exposes
something fundamentally new and
interesting about evolutionary biology
which is that sexual autonomy matters to
animals freedom of choice is not merely
a political concept
discovered by suffragettes and feminists
in the 19th and 20th centuries but it's
actually an evolved feature of the
social and sexual lives of other species
especially in ducks how does this work
well if the female mates with the male
she prefers
is she gets the green head in the
quack-quack-quack that she likes and
then her male offspring will share that
those traits and be sexually preferred
by other female ducks who have
co-evolved those same aesthetic
preferences but if she's forcibly
fertilized then her male offspring will
either inherit a random trait or one
that she specifically rejected which
means that her offspring will be less
attractive to other females so anything
the female duck can do to prevent force
fertilization through physical
resistance or behavior will evolve
because she will be rewarded with more
grandkids right so what this means is
that aesthetic norms these shared ideas
about what is beautiful among ducks
gives female ducks the evolutionary
leverage to advance their freedom of
choice in the environment of persistent
sexual coercion and sexual violence
right this is really stunning in fact we
know these ducks or six are so
successful because in species where 40
or 50 percent of the copulations
are forced only 2 to 5% of the eggs in
the nests are fathered by males who are
not the social partner what that means
is that females have a 98% successful
birth control device that is
behaviorally deployable in the vaginal
tract in response to to sexual violence
right that's like FDA approval right and
what that shows is the power of female
choice to advance the sexual autonomy of
individual females one of the
interesting things we learned from
examining sexual conflict in Docs is
that the genital arms race between males
and females is not really a fair fight
in fact the advances in beat and mail
coercive capacity are really about
control over female outcomes
right there about controlling physically
controlling fertilization
however the countermeasures that females
evolve are not actually about power or
control they merely re-establish the the
the freedom of choice if you will the
flat playing field in which individuals
are free to choose who they like right
now this this sexual autonomy is not
actually about control or control over
other people's or over other individuals
sexual outcomes that's fascinating
because this this asymmetry between male
coercion and female resistance in duct
sex has really fascinating parallels to
a patriarchy and feminism in cultures
today so for example patriarchy is
historically and even in a modern sense
about coercive control over female
reproductive autonomy
whereas feminism is really an ideology
of freedom of choice right and that's so
that same asymmetry between male power
and and freedom of choice is elaborate
and present today and we can see this
explicitly because patriarchy and men's
rights and insell movements all
articulate feminism as a countervailing
force of control over male reproductive
outcomes but that's a fantasy in fact a
the the sexual autonomy includes the
freedom to be rejected which is a lesson
that we learn from duck sex
[Music]